John I don't know if you know this but
apparently Google is going to Mars oh
I'm going with them
[Music]
they're asking me to make a video on why
I should be one of the first hundred
people to colonize Mars and so I'm doing
that now I'm in prime physical condition
I've read Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars
trilogy like 700 times as such I know
all about Mars as post-capitalist future
and I'm willing to support that endeavor
with my very life as a purveyor and
expert in green technology I'll totally
be able to make sure that we don't screw
up Mars the way we screwed up earth also
for the same reason I know all about
geoengineering which when you do it on
Mars is called terraforming and because
of my video blog project I'm very used
to communicating with my family in a non
converse ative fashion which is
important when you live 40 light minutes
away from everything you've ever known I
just wrote a song about Google taking me
to Mars
please Google take me to Mars I wanna go
Mars the first thing that I ever wrote
that was published an actual print was
called let's go to Mars it was published
in space Times Magazine the magazine of
the American Astronomical Society let me
give you a little excerpt Google so that
you know how dedicated I am isn't it
obvious that Mars is calling to our
world it's a little bit too coincidental
for me almost like there is someone or
something out there giving a signals to
go to Mars we need to listen Hank is it
true that you're a founding member of
the Mars Society thank you for asking
yes I am when people get on my nerves
I'm very good at diffusing the situation
for example recently when my brother
challenged me to a beep eating contest
without first consulting me on whether
or not I would like to have a beeping
contest and second apparently forgetting
that we agreed last year to never have a
beeping contest again I didn't get angry
at my brother I didn't tell my brother
off I did not start a fight I was able
to defuse the situation by sticking
safety pins into the head of a peep
version of my brother I'm trained in
biochemistry computer science and
creative nonfiction writing all three of
those things are going to be extremely
important in the success of the Mars
colony I've got a stomach like a rock I
could be anything
I could eat this P version of my brother
that's been sitting on my desk for like
six months I could eat that I must have
a couldn't complain okay I'm definitely
not gonna eat this sorry I bit your head
off John
this is no longer peep I can't even
squeeze it I think that's actually where
I end up not being able to go to Mars is
because I have digestive problems and
they can't handle that so ah ah my head
came off and then the top of my head
came off of my head good morning Hank
it's Tuesday December 9th I don't have a
head I don't have a body
oh look perfect for each other if only
we could find some way to get together
why don't you use that rod that's
sticking out of the base of your neck
well that's a fantastic idea this isn't
actually very much better why am i
British welcome to the degeneration of
my mind to be honest they stopped
selling peeps everywhere in the world as
soon as Easter is over there no more
they ship them back to the peep from to
be happy jumpy peeps uneaten by human
mouths so I'm sorry about that but I
can't I can't do it because there are no
more peeps and I can't eat this because
it would break my teeth so I don't know
maybe I lose maybe I lose I lose fine I
lose I lose you pay me to contest aruna
didn't want to do it anyway check out
the format nerdfighters calm for more
information on the barbering book club
going postal worms will be able to go up
now I'm sorry I'm still working on
slaughterhouse-five have been really
slow but that's coming up to John I
think we should make videos more often
if people are interested in us making
videos more often you can leave a
comment in the comments you can just say
I would like you to make more videos
more often based on the reaction that we
get we'll figure out whether or not we
want to make more videos more often so
it's really up to you guys commenting a
youtube or nerdfighters comm just let us
know we like to feel appreciated and
comments are one of the ways that we we
feel appreciated John I will see you
later